the App Store is the world's largest app
marketplace carplay will also support
third-party navigation oh hey we made it
alright alright you get the point
apples annual Developers Conference was
a little bit different this year and by
different I mean there was no live
audience and it was streamed yes my dog
was finally able to attend what wasn't
different two hours of new software
features for your iPhone iPad watch and
Mac I've rounded up the biggest
announcements by operating system
marking what I think are the most
exciting features and added some crowd
responses for old times sake and also
marking the most met features yes
denoted by crickets first up iOS 14 the
biggest change you can now decorate and
organize your home screen there's a new
feature called app library which will
group your apps into categories so you
don't have to make your own folders or
flip through pages and pages of icons
your main home screen can now be
customized with widgets too like weather
or your calendar I'm also excited about
the new messages features you can now
pin your most important chains and you
can reply to specific messages inline
also great a new translation tool
what are your store hours quite listen
lessor does this at the end up the mess
stuff well Siri no longer takes up the
whole screen sure that's great but it's
not useful if the assistant isn't any
smarter sorry I didn't like that and
then there are more ways to customize
your mom oh geez including with a mask
because well because I have to say I was
super excited about all the watch OS 7
features we heard about today though I
was left expecting some more - yes it's
finally getting sleep tracking like
other wearables it will show you your
periods of sleep and when you wake up
and if you're worried about battery life
well it will remind you to charge when
you wake up Apple watch is the first
watch to deliver
automatic detection when you start
washing your hands and sensing of how
long you actually wash yeah this is
pretty great because counting yourself
during hand washing is hard I can't say
I'm psyched about this Plus with the
global pandemic going on I was expecting
to hear more about some health features
perhaps that will come with the next
watch hardware release iPod OS didn't
get as many features as in years past
but Apple did fix some longtime problems
an incoming call will no longer take
over the whole screen you can also
search from anywhere the Apple pencil
unlocks a whole bunch of new handwriting
features so instead of having to switch
between typing and writing you can now
use the scribble feature to write into
search fields and more yes things seem
to be more easily accessible but getting
around is still confusing an iPad OS
also wears the multi-user support for
the iPad Apple parents have wanted this
for years and not on the Apple TV and
lastly there is a lot of buzz around the
next version of Mac OS called big sir
the operating system is getting a full
visual overhaul the biggest news is that
Apple is moving its Mac's from Intel
processors to its own Apple silicon why
are they doing this when we make bold
changes it's for one simple yet powerful
reason so we can make much better
products well specifically it should
make battery life better and yes there
will be other major performance
improvements and the ability to run
iPhone and iPad apps natively on the Mac
Apple is working with app makers now to
start the transition and it will ship
the first Mac later this year with the
new chips but Tim Cook also said there
would be more Intel Mac's coming soon my
reaction to this is both a little and a
little
all in all it was a pretty packed
keynote without me having to go to a
packed theater to hear the news and
listen to a lot of superfluous clapping
I'm not sure why we haven't been
attending Apple events this way
for years